hey 42 here if you had purchased the
computing power found inside an iPhone
5s in 1992 it would have cost you three
point five six million dollars welcome
to RIF Lenin owned nine Rolls Royces
humans spend 13% of their lives not
focusing on anything in particular
fishing lakes in remote areas of
California are stocked up by throwing
baby trout out of planes flying over the
water at 200 miles per hour there is
more water in the Earth's core than in
all of its oceans prisoners waiting to
be executed on death row in America are
given a physical beforehand to ensure
that they are fit enough to die until
1961 cocaine and heroin could be bought
over the counter at Harrods Kevin kaduk
the co-writer of all about that vase has
only received five thousand six hundred
and seventy nine dollars from a hundred
and seventy eight million plays of the
song on streaming services
that's roughly zero point zero zero zero
zero three dollars per stream in 1717 ad
Emperor Hadrian declared attempted
suicide by soldiers a form of desertion
and made it a capital offense the
ancient Greek philosopher Heraclitus
attempted to cure a serious illness by
lying in the Sun covered in cow dung he
died the following day a study showed
that prison inmates in Chile have better
mental health than the average American
the theoretical process of knocking a
meteoroid of course with a nuclear
explosion is called an x-ray slap four
million years ago rats in South America
were the size of hippos the Pentagon is
successfully hacked 250,000 times a year
and unser
we hacked 10,000,000 times a day a whole
orange will float on water but it's
synched if you peel it Stephen Hawking
was born exactly 300 years to the day
after Galileo died thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2